- Hop!
(musique rock)
- Le Qatar est un des pays
les plus riches au monde.
Avec l'argent du pétrole,
la capitale, Doha, a émergé
du désert pour devenir
une ville ultramoderne.
Pour accueillir la Coupe
du monde et en mettre plein
la vue, les émirs ont investi
220 milliards, du jamais vu.
La Russie n'avait dépensé
que 12 milliards;
le Brésil, 14 milliards.
"Ces routes, dit-il, relient
les itit stades avec un réseau
rapide qui va permettre
aux spectateurs d'éviter
les embouteillages."
Une toute nouvelle ville
a été construite autour
du stade principal.
Tout est rutilant :
ststades climatisés, hôtels,
routes, stations de métro,
un train rapide.
L'envers du décor,
c'est que ceux qui ont construit
tout cela l'ont fait au péril
de leur vie et de leur santé.
(klaxons)
♪ ♪ ♪
Au Népal, des collègues
ont retrouvé pour nous
certains de ces travailleurs.
Birendra a vu u au Qatar
pendant quatre ans.
Il ne touchait que 300 dollars
américains par mois, alors qu'il
travaillait six longues journées
par semaine, sous une chaleur
torride, au-dessus de 40° l'été.
BIRENDRA PASMAN,
ex-travailleur au Qatar
- Je devais transporter
des câbles et les installer.
Tout allait bien, mais,
après trois ans, j'ai commencé
à avoir mal à une jambe.
- L'ouvrier s'est blessé
à la jambe plusieurs fois,
mais il prenait des antidouleurs
pour continuer de travailler,
jusqu'à ce qu'il peine à tenir
debout. Craignant qu'au Qatar
on lui ampute la jambe,
il a attendu ses vacances
annuelles pour consulterun méde.
- Les médecins m'ont dit
que mes os se désintégraient,
qu'ils étaient abîmés
dans toute ma jambe.
- Une chirurgie sauve sa jambe,
mais les séquelles seront
permanentes. Le jeune père
de famille n'est plus capable
de rester debout longtemps.
Selon des chiffres de l'État
du Népal, chaque année,
des milliers de travailleurs
reviennent au pays
gravement blessés.
Et près de 10 000 Népalais
seraient morts, depuis 2008,
sur les chantiers du Qatar,
des autres pays du golfe
et de la Malaisie.
♪ ♪ ♪
Urmila et son fils font
sécher du riz sur le toit
de leur logement. La mèrere de
quatre enfants raconte ce que
son mari faisait au Qatar.
Ram Lodh a travaillé 8nsns
au Qatar. Sa femme n'a jamais
cessé d'avoir peur qu'il se tue
ou se blesse en tombant
d'un échafaudage.
Jamais elle n'a craint
qu'il meure dans son sommeil.
Le mari d'Urmila, qui avait
35 ans, serait mort d'un arrêt
cardiaque, ce qui est considéré
comme une mort naturelle.
Cela évite aux autorités
qataries d'enquêter
sur les causes du décès et,
à l'employeur, de dédommager
la famille. 60 % des décès sont
ainsi définis comme des morts
naturelles. Cela ne tient pas
la route, selon leONONG
qui défendent ces jeunes
travailleurs.
MARIE-JOSÉ TAYAH, Organisation
internationale du travail
- On a recensé plusieurs cas
où des jeunes sont morts
d'un arrêt cardiaque,
et il est important de faire
plus d'investigations.
- Plusieurs de ces arrêts
cardiaques sont probablement
causés par un stre t thermique,
qui peut être fatal.
Le Qatar a indirectement reconnu
le problème en interdisant
le travail de 10 h à 15 h 30
durant lesoiois d'été.
♪ ♪ ♪
Birendra n'a rierereçu
du Qatar, mais il a eu
des compensations de l'assurance
et de son gouvernement,
ce qui lui a permis d'ouvrir
un comptoir alimentaire.
- Avec la blessure à mjajambe,
je ne pouvais plus faire
de travail exigeant et
je ne pouvais aller nulle part
à cause de la douleur constante.
Un médecin a suggéré que j'ouvre
une petite boutique.
- Le commerçant ne fait pas
assez de revenus pour payer
de bonnes écoles à ses enfants.
Si ce n'était de son handicap,
il retournerait travailler
au Qatar. Plus de 2000 Népalais
quittent chaque jour pour aller
travailler dans un des pays
du golfe. La voltété d'offrir
une vie meilleure à leur famille
est plus forte que la peur
de mourir sur un chantier
dangereu